[موسيقى]
في مجله فورين افيرز مقال يرى ان اسرائيل
لن تستطيع حسم الموقف في غزه على نحو
ترضاه لا يستبعد المقال تحول غزه الى
مستنقع يصعب على الجيش الاسرائيلي الخروج
منه ويشير الى ان حماس تستطيع التكيف مع
واقعها الجديد من خلال الاعتماد على شبكه
الانفاق واستخدام البنيه التحتيه المدمره
وتلال الانقاذ لصالحها كما يمكنها الى
جانب جماعات المقاتله الاخرى داخل غزه
البدء بنشر انتحاريين يستهدفون الجنود
الاسرائيليين صحيفتها ارتس كتبت عن ظهور
مقاتلي حماس من جديد في وسط وشمال غزه
مشيره الى تقارير تتحدث عن تجدد المعارك
في مدينه غزه ومناطق في الشمال اعلن الجيش
سيطرته عليها في وقت سابق تقول الصحيفه
انها محاوله من حماس للتاكيد على وجودها
وسيطرتها وهي تلحق بالفعل من خلال تكثيف
هجمات في شكل حرب عصابات اضرارا بقوات
الجيش قال تقرير في صحيفه واشنطن بوست ان
بلينكن يحمل هذه المره في رحلته الى الشرق
الاوسط رساله معقده فحتى مع استهدافها ما
سماها التقرير ميليشيات في سوريا والعراق
تسعى الولايات المتحده في النهايه الى وقف
التصعيد ضد الجماعات المتحالفه مع ايران
التقرير يلفت الى ان المسؤولين الامريكيين
يدركون العلاقه بين الحرب في غزه والهجمات
ضد المصالح الامريكيه وهذا ما يفسر دفع
بلينكن نحو تسريع صفقه بين حماس واسرائيل
ربما تقود الى وقف دائم لاطلاق النار في
صحيفه الاندبندنت نقرا لبيل ترو تقول ان
الهجمات التي وافق بايدن عليها كرد على
مقتل الجنود الامريكيين تخاطر بتصعيد
التوترات في الشرق الاوسط وتنظر بما هو
اسوا تتساءل الكاتبه عن مدى فعاليتها في
وقف الهجمات ضد الاهداف الامريكيه وتحذر
من ان الخطوه تهدد بصرا واسع النطاق في
المنطقه ما دامت حرب غزه مستعره نختم من
صحيفه الجارديان التي نشرت للكاتبه نسرين
مالك ترسم واقعا صعبا تعيش فيه نساء غزه
ظروفا قاسيه في ظل غياب الرعايه الصحيه
والجوع والنزوح تستند الكاتبه الى تقارير
امميه احصت عشرات الالاف من الحوامل
اللاتي اضطررنا للولاده من دون مسكنات
للالم ولا تخدير ووسط غياب لادنى شروط
النظافه ثم يتعين عليهن اذا بقين على قيد
الحياه التاقلم في بيئه شديده التعقيد كيف
للغرب ان يتجاهل معاناتهن تتساءل
الكاتبه